good morning everybody welcome to Sunday
morning science John Perry here today is
a fun day we're gonna do just QA QA
about evolution so if you have questions
about the process of evolution in
particular you know a lot of the details
like what date a certain species was
alive those sorts of things I'd have to
look up but things on the on the process
of evolution questions that you might
have things you might have heard I'm I
will do my best to answer all of the
questions that you might have so let me
just I I got a couple of little uh you
know
welcome chats here already let's see
Rohini asks is Jackson 13 now yeah I
think he is 13 he might be 14 I actually
haven't seen him in a little bit he's
over in Oregon and I'm now here in
Montreal but yet I I did a series of
videos with my nephew Jackson and we
about the skulls of Peru the supposed
alien skulls of Peru and I'm actually
getting ready I might make a couple more
of those videos and put them up on my
main channel this data this data clearly
Channel so that'll be cool
for your evolution questions if you can
do at stated space casually I will be
able to see those it will pop up in
orange for me here but it looks like we
already have one from Tom holes do
chimps ever get born with a tail like
humans sometimes do I'm actually not
sure I imagine that they would I mean we
it happens sometimes in humans so I'm
assuming it would happen in chimps as
well but we really don't I mean the
number of chimpanzees alive today is
tiny compared to the number of humans
and you know most of them live in the
wild so I don't I don't know that that's
ever been documented but I mean
certainly if it can happen to us it can
happen to them
can you make a video on evolutionary
stable strategy that that would be a
good good thing to do sometime an
evolutionarily stable strategy is one
that that works in the long run and so
it doesn't doesn't tend to change and
evolution will pull things towards
stable strategies within a specific
environment so yeah doing a whole video
on that would be interesting there's a
lot of really there's this is really
important when it comes to relationships
between different organisms when they
when they they get locked into symbiosis
and also it's really important in
signaling theory so when different
organisms come start communicating with
each other if they are dishonest and
they're signalling so there's there's an
example of this with fiddler crabs
fiddler crabs then the male's will grow
these giant arms that they use for
fighting and sometimes if their arm gets
ripped off they'll regrow a new one
really quickly that's not strong at all
but it looks big and strong and so
they're actually there they're lying
there being dishonest
it's a dishonest signal they can not
actually want to fight with it and
that's not a very evolutionarily stable
strategy because if everybody starts
doing that then the signal loses its its
validity it loses its strength and
individuals will start to call the bluff
but if there's if there's low enough
dishonest signaling in a population
it can actually be evolutionarily stable
at a certain limit so it's a really
interesting concept that we see
happening in in biology here I've got I
had on Twitter and on Facebook I had
posted letting people ask questions
ahead of time and one question that I
got and by the way I'll be addressing
your questions here too but one question
that I got ahead of time was why did we
evolve soft skin you know humans have
very soft skin
you know this this question came from
Maryland who was a nurse and also my
wife she's she was the first person who
has a question she had a little bit of a
heads up on this but you know she's a
nurse and she sees people come in with
injuries and quite often and it seems
almost dangerous that we have skin
that's as soft as it is when we're
trying to answer a question as to why
something evolved it's actually really
really tricky to figure this out to ask
to answer these with these why questions
what we really want to know when we're
asking that is what selection pressures
selected for in this case soft skin and
that that is extremely difficult to
figure out we also need to know you know
what was the condition before soft skin
existed that that was there you know
what was the precursor to that and the
the best way to try and start answering
these types of questions these why
questions is to ask just what is the
function of soft skin and it's that's an
interesting to try and think about I
mean having soft skin gives us the
ability to have sensory receptors all
over our bodies if you look at a crab
for example covered in a hard
exoskeleton they have trouble sensing
the world they have to actually have
little holes that are poked in their
exoskeleton where a soft tissue can come
out a little bit and act as a sensor to
either you know taste their surroundings
or to I to feel their surroundings and
they also have really thin hair like
protrusions that come out of their
exoskeletons that allow them to feel you
know those can get bent and that that
can act as a sensory mechanism but there
are all sorts of problems that you have
when you have really you know tough
outer shell that we just don't have we
we can sense everything and it's amazing
and I imagine that that for whatever
reason was more of an advantage for
animals most animals on land
because most animals on land have quite
a bit of soft skin of course you've got
reptiles and so on that have scales but
between those scales usually except for
in the case of snakes and a few lizards
that are really covered in scales
usually there's a lot of more sensitive
skin between those scaled sections and
then so so we can think that maybe you
know one of these selection pressures
was for being able to sense our
surroundings better
it seems that soft skin evolved in
mammals that were covered in hair which
was hair is also very protective sort of
like scales not nearly as protective of
scales but it is very protective and
then humans lost hair probably after we
started using clothing after we started
using some sort of covering to protect
our bodies and the reduction of hair
again it's one of these why questions
that it's hard to hard to to figure out
why several things have been suggested
for that one is that we the loss of hair
helps helps us with parasites and if you
look at chimpanzees for example they're
constantly grooming they're constantly
pulling parasites out of each other and
out of themselves that's a lot of work
that's a lot of energy expended which we
don't have to do because it's so easy to
find a parasite on our body we don't
have hair and then the the other the
other thing that's been proposed is that
we went through a semi-aquatic stage or
we were maybe feeding in tide pools and
things like that a lot and during that
semi-aquatic stage a reduction in hair
helped us swim better a lot of people
say there's not good evidence for that
but yeah so we've we've got this strange
evolutionary history we we are mammals
mammals tend to have soft skin there are
a few exceptions there are some scaled
mammals
you know armadillos and so on and
pangolins but for the most part mammals
are protected by their fur and they have
soft skin underneath and we then lost
that fur I would like to point out that
we have a really beautiful adaptation in
our skin where when we're when we're
being rough on a on a patch of skin a
particular patch of skin we will grow
keratinized sections so this will
actually create a bunch of scale of
cells fill them with keratin those cells
will die and they'll become a shield so
if you play guitar a lot look at these
really strong calluses on the tips of
your fingers if you you know do if
you're a welder if you work a lot with
metal with wood you're gonna develop
really strong calluses on your hands and
so on and so we're actually pretty dank
efficient at protecting ourselves
through this what's normally pretty soft
skin and a lot of the injuries that you
see that we're getting are because we're
doing crazy things like we're you know
we're riding motorcycles and we fall in
that rips right through our skin we are
you know riding bikes and skateboards
and driving around in cars so a lot of
things that we do that really do mess up
our skin it's because we're doing these
new weird things that we do not actually
do in our evolutionary history when our
soft skin
became the norm so okay getting lots of
questions here
I've got a question from oxide and I
hopefully am I saying your name right
Akash he says he's 11 years old
any ask about the microbes found in in
Antarctica Lake they seem very different
I actually do not know about these
microbe was found in Antarctica Lake I
do know that we've been finding microbes
in glaciers and that had just been
frozen for you know long long periods of
time and as those glaciers thaw out
those things reading released again and
some of them might even be able to be
revived and live their lives again so
it's kind of like you know Jurassic Park
were bringing these fossils back to life
accidentally by thawing out the glaciers
that's that's really all I know about
that situation though
gaurav asks how do we know that all life
on Earth had a single point of origin
and why is that that's a good question
so there are when we think about the
origin of life you know the origin of
life is not solved but there are reasons
to believe that the origin of life is
something that's obvious obviously it's
rare like as far as we know life only
exists on earth but there are reasons
that physicists are starting to tell us
that that you know if weif evolved here
it's it's probably evolving elsewhere as
well and if conditions on Earth were so
good too for life to evolve once it
probably should have emerged more than
once now the reason that you wouldn't
really see life emerge now denovo right
it's because anything that's using
biomolecules and anytime the the
environment produces biomolecules on its
own those are going to
eaten by something like all the
organisms that exist right now they have
a huge head start on anything new that's
starting to come into existence so it's
kind of like new life-forms cannot
evolve now for the same reason that a
new search engine cannot overthrow
Google Google is you know in the
beginning of this whole search engine
thing you had Yahoo you had Google you
had a there's a bunch of other ones you
know Microsoft has their versions I
don't remember what they are now
but Google just dominated the search
engine world because they for whatever
reason they got in they got a they got a
head start and they ended up just
beating out the competition early on and
they took over everything and now
there's no one who wants to start a
search engine has a prayer of beating
out Google they they're just this giant
really efficient industry now it's super
hard to compete with them and it's the
same situation for new life-forms that
would be popping into existence now like
as soon as you start getting these vile
molecules that are that are similar to
life life will eat them and assimilate
them into their at their own bodies and
we think that something very similar
happened early on and the origin of life
one or a few organisms dominated and
nothing else can really compete
afterwards there are three domains of
life so we have bacteria archaea and
eukaryotes and you can sort of think of
those as three sort of independent
origins eukaryotes are a little bit
different but archaea and bacteria might
have been separate origins of life but
the they were able early on they would
have been swapping jeans kind of
willy-nilly so you would have these
cells that are compartments and genes
can be held inside of them and there was
a lot of horizontal gene transfer so we
the big difference between archaea and
bacteria the big difference is in their
ribosomes the ribosomes which is the
structure that builds protein is
significantly different in the two but
it's identical at its core so the very
core of the ribosome is identical even
in bacteria and archaea and and it's
identical also in eukaryotes we are
eukaryotes these these more complex
cells that did have well I mean we're
multi-celled organisms but you there are
single-celled eukaryotes as well that
are just they've got a nucleus and
they've they've got mitochondria and so
on and the the the main reason that we
think that everything either came from
two origins that ended up swapping a lot
of genes early on or just one origin and
it split early on is because the genetic
code is the same close to the same in
all organisms and the ribosome at its
core is identical almost atom per atom
at its core in all organisms and the
chances of that happening twice just
randomly is pretty much zero so we think
that the we think because of those two
things that there was there was either a
single origin or or multiple origins but
one ribosome that the genes for that
ribosome ended up dominating all of
these cells that exists and so that's
why we have these very very similar
ribosomes and all organisms so either a
single origin or multiple organisms with
a quick takeover sort of like and and
with with Yahoo and Google and all these
other search engines you had one that
ended up dominating and it just took
over everything so hopefully that
answers that question let's see
Schad asks what is the best simple way
to explain evolution to someone well I
would recommend sharing with them these
stated clearly animations the the reason
that I started stated clearly that which
is my my other channel where I do these
animations about how evolution works
genetics and evolution the reason that I
started that is because I was having
trouble explaining evolution to friends
of mine I was living in Tennessee when I
first got the idea to do this and my
friends there were very much against
evolution and and they were also not
really willing to read a whole textbook
on it and my favorite lessons on
evolution where it was a series of
videos by Richard Dawkins called I think
it's like growing up universe or
something like that but it's really
great if you can find it it's it's a
series of talks that he did early on in
his career is like young Dawkins and he
it was kind of before hid he got all you
know full atheists and started his
atheist project but he he he does this
really great series on really so it's on
genetics and evolution but it's it's
peppered with little insults at
Christianity his his his it was kind of
like a little preview of what was to
come and Dawkins career and because of
that when I would show it to people they
didn't like it and so I wanted to start
something that was similar in its
simplicity to that little series but was
just friendly a lot more friendly and
just talked about you know what
evolution is and how it works so I
started this this channel the stated
clearly Channel and those videos really
are designed to teach someone to to
share evolution with someone who's
really new to it and maybe even
reluctant to understand how it works so
that's kind of a good starting starting
point so self-promotion as well but
Andrew asks can you explain what is
meant by information creationists often
state evolution cannot add information
so what is information and how is it
added this is ok so genetic information
this word information is used
differently by different people and it
can be very very confusing you know if
physicists will say that all matter
contains information about itself so if
you a bus contains that's driving down
the road contains information about its
size about its mass about its its
trajectory and if you get hit by that
bus that information is immediately
transferred into your body you there as
well
parts of that information you know
things about its mass and its speed that
gets instantly transferred into your
body and information about your body
gets transferred into that that bus so
there's that's that's how physicists
think about information but genetic
information is different than just basic
physical information genetic information
is information that exists and that is
that is shared and what really can be
described as a communication system that
exists between the genome and the
ribosome
the ribosome is the structure that I was
talking about earlier it that that it
reads genes and takes that information
and it uses that to build proteins and
things start to get weird for a lot of
people when they hear about information
and communication systems inside of
cells but there's an there's no
whoo-whoo here like everything all
communication systems really are
physical at the core even a computer you
know the the code and your computer the
zeros and ones we talk about it in in in
in zeros and ones but it's actually it's
actually running on a physical substrate
the zeros and ones they're actually
different voltages inside of a computer
so there's there's a physical basis for
this information and so information is
not some magical weird new thing outside
of
physics it's a communication system
that's set up it has rules that govern
it and those rules have to come into
existence in the case of the genetic
code those rules came into existence
through the process of evolution and
there is a field of evolutionary biology
called the signaling theory which
explores how it is that signaling
systems communication systems emerge
between different entities that are
under selection pressure to to cooperate
as they're evolving and so signaling
theory if you want to look that up is
I'm actually planning to do a whole
series of videos on this the origin of
genetic information in the first place
and what we can learn about that from
signalling theory but it is it is quite
a bit to wrap your head around when
you're first starting but in short we
have a really good understanding of how
communication systems evolve and as far
as is adding new information so this
thing that creationists say you cannot
add new information now that the genetic
system already exists adding new
information taking information away
editing information all that happens
through mutations mutations are what
caused that some mutations are
completely random they're caused by the
environment others you wouldn't want to
totally say are random because like a
like a HIV for example will insert its
genome into your genome if it infects
you and it does that in a non-random way
it actually targets certain parts of
your genome that are highly active so
when it gets into a cell it has a an
enzyme that detects a certain enzyme
that you use to to to take DNA and
convert that into RNA which is then used
as a signal and it wants its DNA well
once it once it once it inserts its its
genome into your genome it wants to
insert that into a spot that's being
transcribed and so it will actually it's
got this enzyme that actually search
searches for a spot in your genome
that's being
transcribed and it inserts itself in
that spot so this is this is a mutation
I mean it's causing a permanent change
in your your your genome but it's a it's
an active process this is an organism
that's evolved to do this it's actively
and so you can kind of consider that to
be a random mutation or you could
consider that to be a a function of this
virus but that's that so that's that's
another case of a change in genetic
information in that case it's a bad
change it's you you now have HIV
once that's inserted into your genome
but there are also other processes like
when you're when you are reproducing you
have enzymes that have evolved to do
this specifically the you have enzymes
that will align your chromosomes
together when you're creating sperm
cells or egg cells and the crumbs on
chromosomes you got from your mother and
the chromosomes you got from your father
they will all match up and they will
swap chunks and that's that's a genetic
shuffling mechanism that actually causes
mutations but those are caused you could
say deliberately by the by these enzymes
that are that are actively causing those
mutations so there's a lot of ways that
information is changed edited there are
deletions of genetic information there
are insertions of genetic information
and over on they stated clearly channel
I have a series of videos I think it's a
three part series on how new genetic
information evolves so you can go check
that out and I have a bunch of really
specific examples of new genetic
information that's that we've actually
observed happen so we've observed the
we've observed this happening in the lab
with bacteria and so on and then we've
observed it sort of in hindsight with
dogs so there's certain mutations that
we we know happened after dogs were
domesticated and I give some examples of
some which are really long gene
duplications
and that that's that that really
lengthen the genome of the dogs that
have that mutation so go check that out
there are lots of ways that genetic
information can be added taken away and
edited through the normal process of
evolution and it's extremely well
understood let's see
Sophia asks how Lamarckian is
epigenetics really how do acquired
traits get into the germline this is
something that's not fully understood so
so for those who who are honor aren't
familiar with these terms Lamarckian and
epigenetics so Lamarck was before Darwin
and he proposed that so the idea of
evolution the idea that of common
ancestry was actually a predates Darwin
by a long a long time the ancient
peoples were talking about common
descent that you know humans somehow
came from other animals that we are
animals and that we came from other
animals people have been talking about
that for a long time scientists in
Darwin's time so naturalist we're
talking about it as well and Lamarque
was one of these people who was talking
about it and he proposed this idea that
the mechanism for evolution that as an
organism strives to better survive in
its environment it will you know like he
gave the example of a giraffe trying to
reach really high will eventually grow
its neck a little bit longer and it's
children will have their next girl a
little bit longer and so there's this
sort of intentional striving that was
causing evolution to happen and Darwin
proposed a very different idea which is
that the the changes that happen in
evolutionary time are essentially random
they're not you can't will yourself to
grow taller to grow a longer neck but
when you have offspring some of them
will naturally have longer necks than
out
and if there is selection pressure for
having a long neck those ones with the
longer neck will be more likely to
survive and reproduce if it the if the
food is up high those with longer necks
are going to be more likely to be
successful and so those are two pretty
different ideas right that that the
organism is striving to survive and that
that it somehow wills itself to grow
longer neck versus this is happening
naturally and then being selected either
for or against as the generations move
forward we have this thing called
epigenetics this phenomena that we that
we've we found and even talking about
epigenetics epic epic just means on top
of so that there are there are things
that control our phenotype our the way
that our bodies behave and are shaped
that don't have anything to do directly
with our genetics they're they're
controlled by epigenetic factors so
these these these these proteins and
structures that sit on top of our genome
can actually change which genes get used
and which genes get turned on which
which ones get turned off at different
times and epigenetics is it's really
important for the development of your
body so when you start out you have
these cells that are basically universal
cells these stem cells that are not
specialized and as you begin to develop
epigenetics kicks in and turns off
certain genes and turns on different
genes in different cell tissues so your
eyeball cells have the same genome the
same genetic sequence as your bone cells
but different genes are turned on and
different genes are turned off and your
eyeball cells versus your bone cells and
that's why they behave differently so
usually when we're talking about
epigenetics we're talking about this
process that happens these these these
proteins that run on top of the genome
and turn things on and turn things off
those proteins are made by the genome
that the genome is what tells the
ribosome which proteins to build
so really the epigenetic system it comes
from the genes but it can then do some
controlling over which genes get turned
on and which genes get turned off and
we've realized recently that sometimes
these epigenetic messages can actually
be passed from parent to child it
appears so people who have PTSD can
sometimes it seems can pass that on to
their children
and you might think I'll let that that's
horrible you're born with PTSD you're
you just high-strung and super stressed
and in most cases today that is a
horrible adaptation the ability to pass
on your extreme phobias to your
offspring and by the way it's it's
fairly controversial as to whether or
not this really is being passed on to
offspring it's it's not fully understood
but but it seems right now that it might
be happening and but in in an
environment where you know if you go to
war and you have experienced extreme
PTSD and then the war is over having
extreme PTSD is now a huge disadvantage
for you but during the war being really
jumpy and being having having these
these these phobias was not a
disadvantage that was actually an
advantage for you to be on edge
constantly it's super stressful but it's
an advantage for you when you're in a
war zone and you know organisms find
themselves in new environments that are
more dangerous or less dangerous all the
time and usually the danger exists from
multiple generations so it actually
makes sense if you're in a highly stress
environment to somehow pass that on to
your offspring so that they're also on
edge it's basically as soon as they're
born a lot of animals are just hit go at
the start right that they don't humans
are special that we go through this you
know we we're at home until we're 18 or
so that's not usual for organisms they
don't get to learn from their parents
it's information needs to be passed on
in the genome right so this is actually
there's an evolutionary reason you know
there's evolutionary logic tells us that
this adaptation the ability to pass on
information about how stressful the
environment is to your offspring that
actually makes sense an adaptation like
that and the question is could
epigenetic information like this end up
permanent in the genome and actually
cause long-term evolutionary change and
the answer is we don't know how we don't
know what the mechanism would be except
for the fact that if your are in a
constant state of stress because of an
epigenetic change for multiple
generations all of your genes are going
to be under a new pressure of this high
this high-stress environment to adapt to
that high-stress environment and do
things differently in that high-stress
environment so there is kind of a way
where an epigenetic effect if it
persists long enough it could cause
actual genetic evolutionary change it
could actually select for traits that
are different than the traits that would
be selected for without that long-term
epigenetic change so you know there is
this there is this way in which an
epigenetic change if it lasts long
enough if it's reinforced long enough
could actually end up resulting in
genetic changes over evolutionary time
indirectly so that there's really no
argument that that can happen like
obviously if if the epigenetic effect
lasts long enough and is reinforced
consistently long enough you are going
to get different traits selected for
different mutations will be selected for
then if that epigenetic effect was not
there that's not really controversial
but we don't know of a direct mechanism
that an epigenetic change can directly
edit or modify the genome it's just not
something that we've discovered yet so
hopefully that answers that question
let's see where am i adhere pit C or
Pete C asks I never understood how sex
evolved I get the benefits but not the
specifics in how meiosis could develop
because you need two halves to join and
you need the cell to only sometimes do
meiosis and most of the time mitosis I
have to have to run so I'm leaving the
question here and I'll watch it later
for the answer Thanks I've gone over
that in my last Q&A actually a little
bit but let me just go over here again
so the the question of meiosis and
mitosis being two different processes
that is actually not at the origin of
sexual reproduction the first organisms
that were reproducing sexually were
single-celled organisms and they really
only did one or one or the other well
you can actually get blended versions of
these so the origin of sexual
reproduction is not super well
understood however we do know that lots
of organisms swap genes with each other
and sexual reproduction is just a really
fine tuned version of gene swapping so
bacteria they swap genes with each other
though they will do what's called
conjugation and one bacterial cell will
a part of its cell wall per part of its
membrane will extend into the other
bacteria and they will actually swap
genes through a channel that develops
between the two and that's kind of like
a really simplified version of sexual
reproduction and we think that sexual
reproduction emerged from a system like
this just gene swapping
taken to an extreme though in sexual
reproduction now we perfectly swap
versions of our genomes with each other
we we have matching chromosomes and
those chromosomes get swapped and
aligned and we do this it's it's a gene
shuffling process that that happens and
we think that that's how it emerged
through through simpler versions of that
that that we see in bacteria and other
organisms and the question now is why
are so many organisms dependent on
sexual reproduction there are lots of
organisms that can only reproduce
sexually
there are lots that can reproduce
without gene swapping also so they can
do ether or they can just they can just
clone themselves over and over and over
again and then they'll swap genes when
they have the opportunity and then there
are organisms like us we are obligate
sexual reproducers and it's not clear if
that obligate sexual reproduction was
specifically selected for like natural
selection favoured that or if we simply
lost the ability to clone ourselves and
we've lost that ability over
evolutionary time and we then became
completely dependent on sexual
reproduction that's not fully clear but
there are lots of benefits to sexual
reproduction that you don't get through
cloning you you can you can get rid of
negative mutations negative mutations
happen more often than men official
mutations and you can actually weed
those out through sexual reproduction
because you're constantly shuffling your
genome and your your some of your
offspring are going to get all of your
your good chromosomes all of your good
genes some offspring will get a group of
bad genes and this is a way to it's a
way to purge these bad mutations and it
avoids what's called Mueller's ratchet
which is this this accumulation of
negative mutations that can cause
actually an extinction and a really
complex organism so the more complex an
organism is the more likely mutations
are to be negative instead of beneficial
and so sexual reproduction enables us to
purge ourselves of these negative
mutations as time goes on in a way that
organisms that just clone themselves
they can't do that so there are lots of
benefits to it the other benefit to it
is that your entire population is going
to be genetically diverse which means
it's harder for a parasite to take over
because each individual in the
population their bodies are
significantly different to where it
makes it difficult for an organism to
adapt and be able to spread through a
population there's just there's certain
individuals they just cannot infect and
we see this with the with the Black
Plague
for example we see that some people were
just immune to it because the black
plague just couldn't their bodies were
different enough that it could not
infect them and we're probably seeing
this with with the virus right now it's
going through our population there are
people that are not heavily affected by
it and it seems to have had more to do
with age than your genetics but people
have mutations on the the ACE 2 receptor
that this virus exploits those people
are actually probably we probably will
find eventually people that are
completely immune to this virus because
they have a different version of that
gene they have a mutation in that gene
that makes it so that the virus cannot
infect them so sexual reproduction it
has a lot of different functions and we
think that natural selection either
favored those so much then it got rid of
the ability to for mammals to clone
themselves or it's also possible that
mammals just lost that ability
throughout evolutionary time and we're
stuck with sexual reproduction now
forever so that that actually does
happen in evolution quite often and it's
unclear as to which one of those things
happen
Tim Smith how did Homo sapiens skin
color change from darker to light
lighter and why well it only changed in
certain populations right
there are there's there's a whole
variety of skin pigment variations that
exist in different human populations and
you're asking why are you asking how and
why so how like if you look at if you
look at a skin cell the the the pigment
of a skin cell is produced by a series
of enzymes that produce the the pigments
that are in our skin and if you look at
the cell the those pigments are covering
the nucleus they're sheltering the
nucleus from sunlight from UV radiation
and in areas that have lots of UV
radiation mutations that increase the
ability to make skin pigments have you
know had been selected for so in in
populations that have lived in really
high radiation environments they are
going to have darker skin by default and
then in environments where there is less
radiation you're gonna have you tend to
see populations that have lived there
for a long time will have lighter
pigment and that's controlled by a bunch
of different genes or lots of genes
involved in skin color so it's actually
hard to just look at someone's genome
and figure out how dark their skin would
be or how light light their skin would
be because there's so many different
genes involved but yeah we have lots of
different there there are two main
pigments there's a there's a it's almost
like a black one and then there's a red
one and there's combinations of that
that give different skin colors that we
see in different human populations and
so the how of that is that you know you
either produce more or less of these
pigments and you either produce more the
red one or more of the black one so
that's how skin color changes and genes
that that control this and then also of
course we have the ability to
create more pigment when we are exposed
to light so there's there's a mechanism
where when we're exposed to skin damage
from UV radiation we start to build more
pigments and our skin cells so we get we
get a suntan and your other question was
hold on I just lost the whole question
here
so why why did it change what selection
pressures the selection pressure is UV
radiation so there's a bunch of vitamins
that we produce and we need UV radiation
penetrating ourselves to produce those
those vitamins so there's a lot of
different chemical reactions that happen
inside of ourselves that we need
sunlight or light of some kind to
facilitate and we've found that we think
that natural selection is really
favoring it's it's favoring this more
than it's selecting againt against
cancer so early on we thought that maybe
dark skin is a darker skin when there's
more UV radiation as an adaptation to
prevent skin cancer but we actually
think that the selection pressure is
stronger on this these vitamin processes
and to create these vitamins so vitamin
D I believe is one of them that's
produced in the skin and requires
sunlight or bright light to be
penetrating the cells in order for
vitamin D to be produced and this is
really important when especially for
mothers and for young children that
they're able to produce this these
vitamins in high quantities so that they
can grow and develop and if you can't if
there's not enough sunlight or there's
not enough light penetrating the cells
you can't produce vitamin D efficiently
and if there's too much sunlight
penetrating cells you also can't create
vitamin D efficiently and so we think
that that's that vitamin D and and other
chemical reactions that we need to
perform in our cells that use light we
think that those reactions are what's
selecting for skin pigment how pigmented
we are in different populations now of
course with traveling we screw that all
up so people who have historically
adapted to their specific environment
with different skin colors those no
longer really work
so well because we've now live
everywhere and that's why it's you know
we're finding that it's important to
take supplements and to get a lot of
these vitamins from your diet and
luckily with modern technology and
modern farming practices we can ship
different foods that are rich in these
vitamins all over the place and we don't
we don't have to live with these
deficiencies even even if we now live in
an environment that doesn't really jive
with our skin pigments so well so okay
I'll shove you massage ass or says we
have hard skin on our feet and on our
palms we have them because those areas
are important to keep safe yeah that's
true we we we have the the skin on the
palms of our feet palms of our hands and
the bottoms of our feet tend to be
harder than the rest of our body because
those are the parts that we use and this
happens through just use so we had this
ability to create to characterized cells
when those parts of our bodies are being
used but also there are the the skin on
our palms is actually there there's a
little bit more padding on our hands and
on our feet than normal and there's
actually a mutation you can get that
will give you extreme padding on your
hands and feet and sexually it's a it's
a problem for people who have this
mutation now because it makes it really
hard to use cell phones you can't feel
very well it makes it so that your your
sense of touch is quite dramatically
diminished but you had these really
great pads on your hands and feet and I
met a girl that has this mutation and
she was she was she was telling me about
it like the you know for her it's you
know when she was younger it was really
embarrassing but now she's over it but
it's the it's the frustration of not
being able to use a cell phone very well
not being able to type on a cell phone
it's just super frustrating for her but
it was it was interesting talking to her
about that let's see
true Indian giorno asks what type of
life can be on Jupiter's moon Europa can
you make some guesses so we think that
Europa might be capable of producing
life on a very different chemistry than
we what we have here on earth and I
don't know the details about that enough
to really comment but we I know that we
are sending a probe there to see if life
does exist because that would be really
cool cuz it's gonna be based on a very
different chemistry I think it's
supposed to be not water-based life but
I believe it's still carbon-based but
not water-based but I could be wrong on
that so don't quote me on that yeah
that's that's interesting I don't know
enough about it to to really say much
Aaron Miller do you know of any examples
of studies done in different fields of
research whose findings overlap to
support the current model of evolution
well yeah I mean there's evolution is
studied by biologists obviously and then
different groups of biologists so you've
got paleontologists that are studying
the fossil record you have geneticist
that are studying genetics and these are
really different very very different
fields of research I mean a geneticist
usually doesn't know hardly anything
about the fossil record this is actually
a problem you see conclusions being made
in genetics that are just not even
accounting for what we see in the fossil
record and they're proposing little
proposal ideas and people in the fossil
record literally shaking their heads
like no you don't understand this is
this has already been solved a long time
ago in the fossil record and then and
the peléan paleontology literature just
look there we already solved this
problem but then you also see people
like physicists are also studying
biology and evolution you have like
Schrodinger who wrote a lot about
biology and you have now we've got
physicists that are looking at evolution
from the perspective of
physics and the perspective of energy
flow it turns out that biology what
biology is doing is it's there what
organisms are doing is they're finding
ways to absorb energy they're really
efficient at absorbing energy and so
physicists study this and and what is
natural selection doing it's making
things better and better at absorbing
energy in the environment and using that
and really at speeding up the process of
entropy organisms you know yep you have
a local reduction in entropy at the
organism level and a local and a broad
increase in entropy at a broader level
if you zoom out and organisms are just
they're just absorbing and using energy
and getting better and better at doing
that that's what natural selection is
selecting for is this ability to absorb
energy more efficiently and so that's
that's really interesting you should
start and see physicists that are
studying biology from this thermodynamic
perspective so yeah it's happening all
over the place
Tom Houle's
what is your favorite Museum on
evolution my favorite Museum because I
love Wales is actually a tiny little
Museum at the College of Charleston that
talks about whale evolution so if you
ever go to Charleston go to the College
of Charleston and go check out their
little tiny whale museum it's absolutely
great and if you catch them at the right
time they'll take you behind the scenes
and show you their research and stuff so
it's that's really cool my favorite
Natural History Museum would be the one
in London the original giant Natural
History Museum there there's also a
really cool one at Oxford and that's
kind of where the Natural History Museum
concept was invented it was in it was in
London so go check that out if you can
that's like the original Natural History
Museum in London there and it's it's
spectacular it's like a the the the most
fancy kid
girl you've ever seen but it's just
instead of trying to you know be
religious it's just showing you how
nature works it's really really cool and
that's where the the concept comes from
it comes from the concept of these these
giant magnificent cathedrals let's do
this to highlight the beauty of nature
and that's what the Natural History
Museum was we get a drink of water here
okay and what order should I read
Richard Dawkins books this is a another
question from true Indian giorno well it
depends on kind of what level you're at
he's written some some he recently wrote
a book that kind of gives an
introduction to evolution which is
called like the greatest show on earth
I think is that one I have it somewhere
somewhere I have it I think it's in my
the other room but that's a good one for
an introduction to evolution but if I
think if you're gonna read any Dawkins
book I think you should read The Selfish
Gene there are parts of it that uh I
think are starting to become a little
bit less relevant but he teaches you how
to look at evolution from the
perspective of a gene and it's super
important to understand how to do this
so yeah I would I would definitely read
that one so I don't really have an order
that you should read things in but
definitely don't skip that one that's a
that's a really good one let's see
I'm getting a lot of questions from the
same people here and apologize for
skipping stuff but let me so true Indian
giorno has asked quite a few questions
and so let me try and get to someone
else here Aaron Miller I've gone over a
couple of yours as well too so let me go
to Schad okay let's see Rama asks will
we lose any finger or nails in the
future
I mean it's happened lots of times
throughout evolutionary history you have
a reduction of fingers or yeah I don't
know of anything it just completely lost
its no birds some birds have no claws
anymore on their on their wings you know
chickens have one claw on their wing
most chickens do but a lot of birds
don't have any claws on their wings
anymore the wing is a modified arm it's
it's there's actually three fingers
inside of the wing and then some some
birds still have two claws like
ostriches have two claws still so they
have at their fingernail a claw and a
fingernail are the same thing just the
claw is a fingernail it's bent around
the finger and usually is curving the so
ostriches still have to and then some
birds have zero so it's been lost in
birds it could definitely be lost in our
future I suppose and we've had the
reduction of fingers quite a few times
and an increase in finger numbers fairly
rare it's you get it a lot in
individuals there's there's you know
there's cats with six fingers that's
pretty common and same with dogs and
you'll get humans everyone's all to have
six fingers but more often is throughout
evolutionary time as the reduction of
fingers the first tetrapods had I think
it was eight fingers that's what we
started with
the really early tetrapods but for
whatever reason that number was reduced
to five and and after it was reduced to
five we had the big radiation of
vertebrates so almost all vertebrates
have five fingers and five toes but then
you see individual groups that have lost
those lost one or two or or more of
those toes horses have lost all of their
toes except for their they have a middle
finger and they have a middle toe and
that's it
so they actually they run around on
their middle fingers they're flipping
you off all the time and that's pretty
interesting and then you have like
llamas they only have two and so on so
yeah the reduction has happened in other
species it could certainly happen in us
as well we don't really use our pinky
fingers that much or pinky toes that
much though I have heard that if you
lose your pinky toe it's a lot harder to
balance so yeah it could happen Schad
I'm having trouble with names but shod
money got asks is virus our virus is
linked to the Tree of Life so we don't
know exactly where the origin of viruses
is not fully understood like the origin
of the first viruses is not fully
understood but they are definitely
linked to the tree of life and that they
they actually kind of just cruise
between branches and the the tree of
life you know viruses that will infect
one species can hop over and start
infecting another species and so their
genome which evolved so it like it the
the current virus for example I don't
want to say the name of it because then
then this this video will get
demonetized but the it's like yeah it's
funny he you can't say the word I got to
get needy monitize but the the current
virus that is infecting us right now we
think hopped over from bats and so it
was evolving within bats and adapting
there and then it hopped over to humans
possibly through penguins there is still
there is still a possibility that it
it's death transition happen in a
laboratory not we don't think it was a
designed weapon but it is still possible
that it happened in a laboratory that's
happened before we've had lab linked lab
leaks and that hasn't been fully ruled
out yet here but what happens is that a
virus that evolved in one organism then
gets into a new organism and evolves and
adapts and that one and so you have this
they can actually even pull genes from
one organism and it and accidentally
insert them into another organism so you
do have this really weird way through
viruses that evolution can actually hop
from one branch of the tree to another
branch of the tree in this sort of
web-like manner and so I like to imagine
that the evolutionary tree with these
little strings going all over the place
two different branches little spider
webs you could say that kind of
represent viruses and we think that
viruses actually they first evolved by
escaping organisms so they were it was a
cluster of genes that escaped its
original organism other people think of
viruses may be a different possible
origin for viruses is that they are just
extremely reduced to parasites so when
when a parasite really does good and
infecting its host oftentimes it'll
start to lose traits lose genes and
become more and more dependent on its
host it can't live freely anymore and
this may have happened to the point to
where you have viruses that are just
super simple organisms that cannot
survive on their own at all they need a
host in order to reproduce so that's one
possible origin for viruses and maybe
both of these things happened in
different cases so viruses might have
multiple origins new viruses might be
emerging now by the reduction of
parasites and new viruses might be
escaping the genomes of their hosts so
yeah that's the possibilities are
endless there but yeah that's what they
do in the tree of life they they hop
around sort of like spider webs between
branches
richard ball says biology is messy
I prefer physics well yeah if you really
dig down deep enough biology is physics
right and Richard ball says viruses have
existed since the RNA world that's
actually some viruses might have existed
since the RNA world I actually think
that's pretty unlikely that something
survived that long but it's possible
that is one other explanation for their
origin but it's it's much more likely
that the viruses that we're seeing now
have evolved de novo since then so
through the reduction of a parasite into
a virus or through just the escape of a
set of genes because we have we have
jumping genes we have there are genes
that we have in our genome that can
actually get into like ticks and stuff
that bite us a lot these jumping genes
can get from us into the ticks and
vice-versa
their jumping genes can get into us and
I've got a I've got a video on that
called horizontal what is horizontal
gene transfer on this data clearly
channel so you can watch that it
explains how that happens and a virus a
virus could evolve from a jumping gene
or quite easily we think gotta poo die
gotham asks do we have any life hacks to
study evolution from home using
computational methods you'd have to
explain a little more you can definitely
evolution in your own backyard you can
look at you know different organisms
what they're doing now and you know do
some comparative anatomy between
different organisms there so that works
but as far as computational methods in
order to do computation on evolution you
usually have to have lots and lots of
data so you would have to
lots and lots of data that you're
collecting in your backyard before you
can really run computations on that see
I'm getting some side conversation here
if you have a direct question do you at
stated space casually and I'll see that
highlighted in orange I'm gonna go but
I'm not saying well let's see I'm seeing
a couple okay here we go I was a little
bit behind in the comments actually I'm
Way behind in the comments let me try
and get one that's been asked by someone
new here
whare of sharma asks i would like to
hear you talk about sexual orientation
and why science has failed to present a
solid theory yet so maybe you're talking
about the evolution of homosexuality I
think that you know humans are just
we're very sexual organisms and most
mammals are very sexual organisms and
they most mammals have they they engage
in sexual activities all the time that
are not for Reproductive purposes
they're for bonding purposes and just
you know getting out a little energy
apparently I think the reason that we
are more sexual than we need to be in
order to reproduce is because that
increases our chances at reproduction so
in general organisms are more sexual
than they need to be they they are
driven to have more sex than they
actually need to in order to reproduce
and in the case of homosexuality you
know I I know a lot I know several gay
men like fully gay only attracted to
other men that have kids so even though
they are really only attracted to men
they still have had yeah they they still
have had partners and they've had kids
with them you know female partners so I
don't really know that homosexuality is
being selected against very hard because
we are such sexually active organisms
sexually driven organisms that we we're
still able to reproduce even if even if
we are homosexual we are able to
reproduce even if we're exclusively
homosexual people still do it sometimes
kind of even if they're not super into
it so because they want to have kids or
and and actually a lot of cases that I
know it was because they were they're
pressured by their culture to get
married and so they did that and they
had kids even though it was not what was
satisfying for them but yeah it happens
and then of course whether or not you
you personally have kids you can help
raise kids and that can be extremely
beneficial for a population and there
are certain
scenarios where survival is so difficult
that it actually takes more than just
two people to raise children and in
those cases having having you know
having exclusive homosexuality in it and
a fairly high percentage of the
population wouldn't be bad at all if
those people are still participating in
raising the children that are being
produced in that population so I don't
think I don't think that homosexuality
needs really its own special explanation
it's just we are hyper sexual organisms
and we the fact that homosexuality can
persist makes sense because it's really
not being selected against very hard
let's see looking for more orange
questions here from people who haven't
asked already we're at 1208 I'm gonna
keep going here for another till till
12:30 Eastern Time let's see Richard
ball have you ever found something in
your bio research that has made you
think there is a major flaw in the
theory of evolution
something magical well there are lots of
things I suppose that aren't they're
hard to study but there's nothing that's
really I mean well nothing with it make
me go go towards magical thinking
because I don't tend that way anyways
but there are certainly things that are
just like just mysterious I mean the
origin of life hasn't been fully solved
and then there are things that are just
difficult to understand like the
evolution of protein complexes is
something that we haven't been able to
study very well because there to study
the origin of a structure we have two
ways to do it really you can look at the
fossil record and if the structure
happens to be something that fossil eyes
as well you can you can get a picture of
its development over time
which is that's the ideal way to do it
and then the other way to do it is
through comparative anatomy so if you're
looking at soft tissue for example you
can look it so the eyeball like how did
the eye evolve you can compare different
organisms see what their eyes are like
and what their functions are you can
kind of get a picture as to how the eye
evolved and that that's actually how we
figured out how the eye evolved it's
your comparative anatomy but whenever
you do that when you're doing
comparative anatomy alone there's a lot
of uncertainty there like that the
actual steps that our eyes went through
you know that we inherited our eyes from
the vertebrates that came before us the
the land vertebrates that came before us
the tetrapods
and they inherited their eyes from fish
which are also vertebrates and they
inherited their eyes from you know
simpler organisms that came before but
the these specific steps and that are
not well understood
so because we can only do comparative
and I mean the eyeball does not
fossilize well but so we don't have as
many steps as we would like with the
evolution of the eye so those things are
difficult and it's even more difficult
when we're looking at protein structures
because those don't fossilize well
either but just recently we have found
this way this really cool way to revive
extinct
proteins by doing comparative genomics
we can actually take the genes from one
organism that has a version of a protein
that's very different than it is in a
different organism and we can combine
those genomes and actually get get what
we think would be the ancestral protein
to pop out and we can study how it works
and this is being done now like
seriously
as a way to study the fossil record of
protein structures and it's really
really cool there was a paper just just
recently on the evolution of hemoglobin
that was published on this and they did
this this we revived a fossil protein to
study how it worked and is really cool
and I'm excited to see how this this
moves forward in the future to explain
more things so you know there's there
are lots of things in biology that I
wish we could enter
and better but we can't because we don't
have enough fossil data and so on what
we are now finding ways to to get around
some of these problems so that's really
cool I'm getting the question why why
don't creationists just stop and believe
in science science has shown us has
shown so many evidences most
creationists do believe in science just
not the science of biology so they're
you know there's lots of creationists
that are physicists there's lots of
creationists that are doctors the and so
on that they'll study medical science
but they just they reject there they're
pretty specific about what they reject
so that the idea that creationists are
anti science in general that's not super
fair in many cases they're just very
specific they reject the science of
biology you know in particularly
biological evolution so why don't we
call theory of evolution as law of
evolution is math involved in evolution
yeah math isn't involved in evolution
but yeah theories and laws aren't the
same thing a law is just a theory is a
broad idea that encompasses a bunch of
data a bunch of observations and a bunch
of laws so a theory is a completely
different thing from Allah and Allah is
just it's it's a we observe time and
time again there's one specific thing
and so it we say that it's a law but
evolution is a is the theory of
evolution is a broad explanation of how
organisms evolve over time and
diversified it into the ways that
they've diversified into now it's not a
lot it's a different thing than a law is
it's it's an overarching explanation
that explains a bunch of laws and a
bunch of observations that we have in
physics and biology
okay moving on Tim Smith asks I've heard
our modern species DNA is so very close
with our biology do you have any ideas
as to how this came about
si I've heard our modern species DNA is
so very close within our biology do you
have any ideas as to how this came about
I don't understand that question are you
saying yeah sorry if you can rephrase
that I'll try and answer that again
I am going to scroll up because there's
a bunch of questions that I had skipped
because they were asked by people who'd
already asked some so let me try and go
back up to those
I'm getting questions about religion I
don't want to talk about those today
let's see Gaurav asks why didn't an
unconquerable virus like HIV jump into
humans much earlier and wipe us out it's
nearly impossible for a virus to cause
the extinction of a species because the
virus first of all the virus isn't the
but evolution doesn't derive viruses to
kill their hosts in fact evolution tends
to drive viruses towards symbiosis with
hosts and towards towards being benign
within its hosts because you know if if
it kills its host it dies with that host
and it has to has to spread before the
host dies and if it's killing it so us
really quickly well spreading becomes
really difficult right so but even a
virus that is selected to kill its host
so there are some cases where it spreads
most vigorously when the host dies this
has been the case for Ebola in certain
cultures because of the way that
funerals work a bowler will spread best
at a funeral and under situations like
that it's under selection pressure to
kill but and let's say let's just
pretend that you could get a culture
that was insisting upon having these
really intense funerals where everybody
would touch the body and get the disease
end up getting the disease and and the
virus was able to just burn through the
population and it was it was selected
for to kill people faster and so it was
getting better and better at killing
people causing funerals and then
spreading that virus would actually die
out before it succeeded in completely
killing a population and the reason for
that is that there and every every
population there's always those few
Hermits that don't participate
and they're not gonna they don't like to
participate in society they're gonna be
out far away and they're not going to
get infected with the disease for
whatever reason so the disease will
actually die out by causing the
extinction of the people that are that
will easily catch it it will die out
before the species that it's infecting
goes extinct so you will have from these
Hermits you will have eventually they
will revive the population and you won't
see the extinction of that species and
because of this is actually really hard
for a virus to cause an actual
extinction of a species because every
species you have just individuals that
end up you know in little pockets that
are not connected to the rest of the
population and those little pockets just
never get infected and so the species
never get goes extinct because of that
see also of course you can get you get
the host that when we all become immune
to a virus and so the it's really hard
for a virus to completely destroy a host
species for multiple reasons
okay
how did sperm and egg cells help a
simple like early microbes multicellular
system and how did it help them
exchanging genes like microorganisms
these cells have more problems so the
development of sperm and egg is a really
interesting question and it's been
pretty well studied but I don't think
there's I don't think there's full
consensus on why we have sperm and egg
cells so this question is is there are a
lot of things to this we have sperm
which are extremely small and then eggs
which are extremely large for cell and
the sperm goes and finds the egg and
fertilizes the egg and so there is this
division of labor that's happened
between male and female so the the
female produces this really strong egg
full of protein and nourishment these
molecules that can really nourish the
fetus as it develops and the sperm cell
has nothing but genes in it for the most
part and yeah we think that's just a
division of labor that evolved between
organisms that were swapping genes with
each other you eventually get this
division of labor where one one benefits
by doing all the work to find the the
egg cell and one does all the work to
build a nourishing environment for the
fetus to grow and yeah that's there's
their equations that we run on natural
selection that can explain why this
division of labor developed or how it
can develop under certain selection
pressures and so all that research is is
pretty interesting but it gets pretty
complex but essentially why do we have
sperm and eggs it's a division of labor
so that one gamete can can focus its
energy on searching for the the other
gamete and the other gamete can focus
its energy on
basically nourishing the fetus which is
going to develop from that from that
gamete okay
so Tim Smith is clarifying here standing
casually it's how extremely close our
species DNA is closer than most other
animals such as chimpanzees DNA or more
different than other chimpanzees in his
area than humans are to humans okay so
so if you look at two different humans
like really from really diverse
different populations so if you were to
look at it's like an Australian
Aborigine and compare their genomes to
like a a Native American for example
these are populations have been
separated for a long time really long
time but their genomes are much more
similar than what you'd find between two
different chimps that live in the same
jungle so the reason for that is that we
went through a more a much more recent
bottleneck than chimpanzees have genetic
bottleneck so we our population went
through some sort of really we almost
went extinct the the lineage that gave
rise to humans we we went through a
bottleneck or there's probably only a
few thousand individuals that were in
existence at that time and that just it
reduced our genetic diversity and we've
been building that genetic diversity
back up since then and it just takes
time so that is why we that's why we
think that we are so similar to each
other
true asks why don't we have a definite
distinction between genre species breed
subspecies in biology well let's just
talk about species for example it's
super hard to define a species because
these these units aren't actually real
they're not real things that exist in
the world
they're categories that humans invent I
mean there's a there's a sense in which
they are real like humans and
butterflies cannot successfully
reproduce with each other and so we are
definitely different species and we are
not going to affect each other's
evolution directly however there there
are ways in which a virus could actually
transfer a gene from a butterfly into a
human genome and so we can actually end
up starting to use that gene eventually
so there are kind of some ways in which
the species are even blurred by viruses
but but the for the most part you know
you can say that a species is a real
thing in the fact that the human species
cannot reproduce with the butterflies a
different butterfly species or a
specific butterfly species but the
things start to get fuzzy when if you
look at like dogs and wolves for example
or wolves and coyotes for example they
can reproduce with each other sometimes
but they tend not to it's super rare for
a wolf and a coyote to reproduce
together and so biologists will say oh
they're different species it's so rare
we can consider them to be different
species because they don't really affect
each other's evolution directly there's
not gene flow between wolves and coyotes
there's some gene flow but not very much
so we consider them to be different
species but then when you look at
bacteria bacteria have gene flow with
pretty much any other species of
bacteria and so how we would define a
species for an animal is different than
how we'd have to define it for a
bacteria so there's no universal way
to describe what a species is there just
is not it's it's a fool's errand to try
and find a universal definition for a
species because biology is too messy so
that's that's why did you have a nice
canter today and my Canon today was a
like most days it's quarantine time so
there's not a whole lot of gatherings
but we you know we visited some family
I've got three minutes so if anyone has
a final question for me that I can
answer in three minutes I will do that
let's see I'm now looking at the most
recent questions and there is a little
bit of a lag so it might take me a
minute to get this last final question
but whoever you are you lucky person go
ahead and write that question and send
it and I will do one more
let me scroll back up and see Oh what is
my favorite exaptation there we go
that's a good question my favorite
exaptation so an exaptation is where a
structure that used to do something else
is then co-opted into a new function to
perform a new function over evolutionary
time I I would have to say that my
favorite exaptation is flight in birds
you have arms that are accepted into
wings and that is just the coolest thing
ever actually I'm gonna change that
there's an even cooler one but it's also
wings it's these uh I'm forgetting what
they're called but they're these these
let these lizards that fly with their
ribs they stick their ribs out and they
can actually fly with them they glide
with them and I forget the name of those
those things but they're super cool so
yeah it's between bird wings and lizard
wings they're not they don't do true
flight these lizards they just glide but
it's really amazing to see then just
flick out their ribs and jump off of a
branch and glide with extreme efficiency
so yeah Tim Tim asks what is the meaning
of life the meaning of life is to
consume energy
apparently I mean that's what natural
selection is is favoring as organisms
that can that can exploit new new energy
sources those are the things that get
favored and do that do that more
efficiently for the for the so they can
reproduce more efficiently so yeah I
guess according to biology and physics
that's what the meaning of life is but
of course hopefully you will find
something more interesting to be the
meaning that drives your life
it's so tempting to do more fees because
people are coming out with really good
questions now oh it's the Draco lizard
yeah yeah that's that that's the flying
one let's see here what's my favorite
animal well that's the humpback whale
obviously can we explain can we explain
lifespan of a species based on evolution
yes sort of not very well but the
basically we are our genes are under
selection pressure to reproduce
efficiently and different environments
select for different amounts of waiting
between bouts of reproduction and so
that's kind of a there's not there's not
selection pressure for living forever
there's selection pressure for living
until you can reproduce and and then
living long enough to then help your
offspring if you happen to be a species
that's evolved the ability to help
offspring you need to be able to survive
long enough to help those offspring
become sufficient so that's what
selection pressure is favoring and
because of that any mutation that causes
us to die after we've reproduced will
not really be selected against it's just
going to be there and so we we have an
expiration date because of that we
reproduce and then we help our offspring
mature and then we die
do animals other than humans get
depressed yes all vertebrates get
depressed and they have the same
receptors for the the emotions evolved
in depression and we actually can we
actually study depression on fish as a
model for human depression for the study
of antidepressants and we've there's a
group of researchers that are really
good at spotting depression in zebrafish
they can actually see the outward you
know behavioural changes in a depressed
zebrafish and they can correlate that
with biochemistry inside the zebrafish
and they study drugs for depression
on those zebrafish it's pretty amazing
that happens so yes animals get
depressed and they can actually like
humans it can cause them to die they can
get so depressed that they don't want to
do anything and they can die from that I
don't it has been reported that dolphins
will commit suicide due to depression
but those claims are a little bit
sketchy but dolphins are the only animal
that I know of that has been reported to
commit suicide due to depression
male spiders know all about dying after
reproduction yes that's true a lot of
male spiders get eaten after they
reproduce how did a motion come in multi
cellular organisms nobody knows what is
the evolutionary basis for acne I think
it's just I think it's a flaw it's an
accident
I don't think acne is an adaptation but
the the the fact that acne is
embarrassing for people it's probably
due to sexual selection favoring clear
clean skin because rashes and things
like acne and so on are our cue
indicating that the person who has it
might not be good at avoiding parasites
and so on and so evolutionary
psychologists think that there might be
an evolved repulsion to acne and other
conditions
because of that so there's actually
selection pressure against acne you
would think but acne is somehow slipping
through the cracks anyways and a lot of
a lot of people have been trying to
figure out what's causing acting and
it's people people suspect that it might
be linked to diet and a whole bunch of
other things so yeah it's it is pretty
mysterious but I do not think it's being
selected for I actually think it's being
probably slightly selected against
when do you see genuine rejuvenation
anti-aging treatments hitting the market
I mean you could say they already have
like we we already live one way longer
than we used to so pretty much all
modern medicine or a lot of modern
medicine and modern nutrition science is
anti-aging technology but as far as
stuff that can really like double our
lifespan Adam I have no clue so I'm
going to end it there
yeah those fun this was I honestly I did
this because I didn't have time this
week to prepare anything any lesson in
Maya I didn't have a guest I do have
some some cool guests lined up in the
future but everything is pending I think
next week I might if I don't have a
guest by next week I'm probably going to
do sorry I'm probably going to discuss
this book here this is an amazing book
the machinery of life and it is about
macromolecules and how they function
inside the cell and again these are
macromolecules the that really in depth
evolution of macromolecules was pretty
hard to study until recently now that we
can revive these old proteins through
these new genetic techniques we can
really start to study the evolution of
these things and I'm very excited about
that but that's for the most part we
don't know how a lot of these things
evolved but this book just shows how
that work and it is amazing and it shows
just how crowded a cell is a crowd a
cell is way more crowded than you
probably imagined it is with all sorts
of different things going on in there
and I'm gonna go over that book it's
probably the best book I've ever read
well definitely it's definitely the best
book I've ever read on microbiology and
yeah or biochemistry
rather and they're very excited about
that so that's probably what I'll be
doing next week unless one of these
guests that I've been talking with
decides to come on or if next week is
the week for them so
so long for now stay curious